[音楽]
皆さんはソファーというものをご存知
でしょうかまさに今僕が寝っ転がっている
これがソファっていうものなんですけれど
も
我々の生活には切っても切り離せないよう
な大切な存在の家具ソファーゆっくり休み
たい時に座ったりYouTuberとかも
でもHIKAKINさんももう
HIKAKINさんといえばこのソファー
みたいなソファありますソファーは本当に
ねもうものによって
座り心地とか家のインテリアとしての見た
目とか何に座れるかとかソファー選びって
すごく大事なんですけども今回私
久々に新しいソファを買いましたちょっと
持ってきます
[音楽]
すごい量だなすごい量のダンボールが来た
ぞ1個でまとまってくるタイプじゃない
ソファだなこれは果たして組み立てる系の
ソファーなのか一体どういう風に入ってる
んだと皆さん気になってると思いますが
早速開けていきましょう
[音楽]
開封の舞い2023年バージョン
無事でした
まず1個
完成しました
[笑い]
このカラーリングホワイトとブラックの2
色のモノトーンでちょっとまとめてみまし
たえ
っさっきやったソファーと一緒
そう
さっき僕が座っていたあのちょっと
カラフルなソファあるじゃないですかあれ
とこれ一緒でヨギボーさんから出てるモ
ジュっていうソファーなんですよあのです
ねみなさん
このソファーが一番いいですこれはっきり
言いましょう
案件じゃないからガチな別にヨギボーさん
のCMで出演させていただいたからなんか
そういうのが働いてるとかじゃねえしもう
個人的に買いました自分のお金でしっかり
と
忖度なしで本当にこのヨギボーの文字って
いうソファーめちゃくちゃ良くてリピー
ターってわけじゃないんですけど
満足度が高すぎて違う色でまた買って
しまいましたでも組み立ててる時から
気づいたと思うんですけどもこれ自分で
カスタマイズできるんですよちょっと
ホームページ見てみましょうか
夢が叶うソファー
文字これすごいのよ後ろ見てもらったら
分かると思うんですけどあの作り替えて
自分で形を変えれるっていうやつこういう
L字に置くこともできますしこれはまあ
ダナープロが足を広げておける今やって
みようか下のやつを前に出すと
ソファーというかちょっとリクライニング
的な感じになったんですけども足が伸ばせ
てこうやって寝れるソファに変わるんです
よこれすごくない
おやすみあとこういうねヨギボーと
組み合わせてなんかこういうベッドみたい
なのも作れますと
あとよくわかんないやもうね
快適すぎるのよ本当にソファーであって
ソファーでないみたいなどんだけでも形が
変えられるっていうのがこの文字という
ソファーでございますで地面が今回買った
のがこのモズトップっていうこれがこの
普通の形のやつが白と黒で2個モチベース
このベースってやった時4ついわゆる足に
なる部分ですね
文字コーナーお部屋の角に置くやつですね
一応この白と黒で2種類買いましたいや
まさにこれなのよ何百もの組み合わせ
理想の空間
驚きの軽さであっという間に作り変え足が
ないソファーはフローリングに傷も跡も
残しません6色のカラーでコーディネート
もお手の物
すごいんですよ6色があってインディゴ
カナリアホワイトパーツ
グラファイトバイオレットテラコッタ俺は
今回ホワイトパーツとグラファイトで固め
たんですけど他の色もねさっきまで座って
たソファにあるのでただソファーを
買い換えたんじゃなくて今まであった文字
と合体させて
めっちゃでけえソファー作れるようになっ
たんですよ1回組み合わせてみましょうか
あとこれすごいのが軽いんですよ
軽い
[音楽]
よし
[拍手]
できました
めっちゃ大きくなったぞもうカメラに
収まりきってないんですけど今までこの4
つぐらいだったんですけども
拡張して
ここまで
伸びましたいやいやもう何人
座れるんこれもうかしこが見えない広角の
カメラでも全部捉えられないくらい大きな
ソファーになりました
いやいやいやいやいやいやいやいや
広すぎだろう
数えてみよう1人
3人5人
66789101112
人乗りますね
すごいそれもこういう使い方だけじゃなく
て
囲めたりするんですよちょっと改造して
みよう
できました家族だんらんシェア作戦です
U字型のソファーも作れてしまうとこれ
すごいなもう使い方が無限大すぎるこれで
さここに机置いたりしたら会議とかみんな
でできるわけだしさっきみたいにバカ長い
ソファーも作れたりしますもう可能性がね
無限大なんですよこの文字っていう
ソファーはもちろん動画で使う時は僕普通
に横に並べてこっち使うと思うんです
けれども逆にこれ無限なりすぎて色んな
組み合わせがあるなと思って結構たくさん
文字手に入ったのでちょっと僕いろいろ
考えてみたのであの
参考までにこういうこともでき
るっていうのを見ていただけると嬉しい
ですでは
VTRどうぞ
[音楽]
シングル一つでできる
文字の座り方です足が伸ばすこともできず
にとても窮屈な思いしますが一番値段が
かかりませんぜひお試しあれノーマル
文字の高さもかなりスタンダードになり足
をも伸ばすことが可能になりました
一人暮らしの方におすすめですまあ割と
ソファーまぁ割とソファーです寝っ転がる
ことも可能ですし友達と2人で映画を見る
ことも可能です寝落ちにご注意をまあ割と
ソファー腕を蹴るバージョンです
腕が置くことが可能になり偉そうな態度を
取ることができますうっすらと女性が両
サイドにいることも容易に想像が可能足を
上に乗せて寝ることも可能とても
便利ですロングベンチ名前の通りかなり
広くなったベンチです一人で寝っ転がって
ももう一人来ることも可能です広すぎて
もう1系とかでは多分
置けない大きさでしょう
L字ロング
L字に配置した文字です
もう寝っ転がっても全然余裕ただこの
サイズのソファーはもう普通の一人暮らし
のお部屋には入りませんそんな方にお
すすめしたいのが
極小L字無理矢理L字にした文字です2人
で座ることも可能ですが足が絡まって
しまうことがあり
喧嘩が起きてしまいます取り扱いにはご
注意しましょうスーパースーパーバイド
赤ちゃんゾーン
文字を最大限に広げた赤ちゃんコーナーの
ような文字の配置ですとても安全です
赤ちゃんがいても問題ありませんキング
オブザエジプトピラミッドモジュール
まるでピラミッドのような高みを目指した
配置になっている文字ですこの高い位置
から見渡す景色は二度と忘れられません
そして物理的に
降りれられなくなります
ザダルマまるでだるま落としのような配置
をした文字ですここから人を見下すことが
できます
ザキングオブゴッドオブ文字
ザルマをさらに改良した上位互換にあたる
文字の配置です
登るのにはとても苦労しますが天井に頭が
ぶつかってしまうほどのギリギリの高さ
思考です
降りる時には強調しましょう
暖炉まるでお家の真ん中に
暖炉を置いてあるかのような文字の配置
ですとても揺れて危険ですきっといつか
落ちてしまいますがこの何でしょうとても
無駄ですMRI検査
文字のブロックをMRI検査の機械のよう
に配置した姿ですこの中に入れることに
より
必然的にMRI検査を受けているような
気分になります決して動かないようにし
ましょうチャレンジザトリプル3段に重ね
た文字の配置です足が長い人じゃないと
いただけませんが足がしっかり伸ばせるの
でとても快適です彼のような短足には
ちょっと
届かないかもしれません使用者は是非足の
長さに気をつけましょうダンジョン
迷路のような配置をした文字の姿です
もはやソファーとしての役割を全く果たし
ていませんこの中に迷い込んでしまったら
最後出るのに5年間はかかります出るのに
5年かかります1000万円分の文字が
あれば
史上最大の迷路を作ってみたいものですね
はいというわけで変幻自在の文字という
ソファーいろんな使い方があることが
分かりましたちなみに俺も新しく買った分
と過去にあった文字合わせても配置しまし
たご覧ください
[音楽]
ここにテレビがあるのでこことかそことか
で座ってみんなでスイッチでゲームしたり
とかここは撮影用ですねこうやって座って
ここで撮影しますこれでねもう
遊びの空間とこの
撮影の空間を2つ色分けしてねモノクロの
方は撮影からの方は遊びっていう色分け
できるようになりましたおしゃれマジで
すごくないですかこの形はもうこの
ソファーさんとできないからかなり満足度
高いですねもう何でも自由にできるんで
本当におすすめで
改めて買ったっていうソファーでしたただ
値段がただ値段がちょっとあのそのあの
そのあのその高い高いのかなちょっと
ソファーの値段の相場がわからないけどで
も家具ってやっぱ高いからこんなもんなん
だろうなちょっと値段見てみましょうか
えっとまずですね
文字ベース
この一番下のこれね一番下のこの土台と
なる文字をベースが1個値段が
38,610円
約4万ぐらい約4万ぐらいです1ブロック
で約4万ぐらいですそして次に文字トップ
これねこの
L字のやつねこれが5万4450円
この2つでも9万5000円ぐらいですね
そして最後文字コーナーこのねこの
角の部分のやつねコーナーのやつが
5万9400円
約6万円ですね今回買ったもの白黒セット
で何円なんだろう大体で計算してみます
文字ベースが何個だ123456785
[音楽]
トータル
77万5000円です
高いかもしれない土台のこれだけで4万
ちょっと高いて感じますけれどもマジで質
がいいんですよもうずっとこれとか使っ
てるけど全然
丈夫だし
壊れる気がしないさすがヨギボーさんって
感じですまず値段高いですけどそれ相応の
本当質の良さありますこれこのセットで何
買ったんだモノクロの値段調べてみよう
39万円分買ってる今回買ったこのセット
でまあ39万円ぐらいですね
まあでもどうなんだろう高級家具屋さんと
かのソファよりか全然安い方かなと思い
ます39万高いな安いです高級家具屋さん
のソファよりは絶対安いし
組み替えられるし色も自由形も自由絶対
こっちの方がいいんじゃないかと俺はね
もう自信を持って言えますねちょっとこの
文字を本当につなげるだけいろんなこと
できるんで年々買い足していって最終的に
はもうバカでかい
日本一でかい世界とか作れたらいいなと
思ってますはいぜひ買ってみてください
シームお待ちしております
[音楽]